[Music]
this is rupture farms
[Music]
these working conditions may seem
harrowing but one blue-skinned mu Dakin
slave named Abe still thinks he has a
pretty good job but after stumbling upon
a rupture farms plans for a tasty new
product Abe abandons his cleaning duties
and sets out to escape the
slaughterhouse so begins Oddworld new n
tasty a remake of 1997 side-scrolling
platformer odd world Abe's Oddysee
but we're not talking about simply
upscaling the original games
pre-rendered 2d graphics no the entire
game has been rebuilt from the ground up
in real-time 3d while Abe's Oddysee
divided its levels into still screens
new and tasties camera Scrolls with a v'
as he walks runs and sneaks through odd
world
it's a thrill to see areas from Abe's
Oddysee that would have required
travelling across seven or so screens
rendered in new and tasty with an
impressive seamlessness this new camera
is also free to give a better look at
the consistently gorgeous environmental
design which has lost none of the
original games style and detail in the
move to 3d for me it felt like new and
tasty presented a literal depiction of
odd world as my mind's eye saw it in
1997 despite the new visuals new and
tasty takes great care to retain the
core side-scrolling platformer that
distinguished Abe's Oddysee 17 years ago
apes a weakling he's extremely fragile
and lacking in offensive capabilities
he's more concerned with surviving his
enemies and destroying them and he does
this by sneaking past them outrunning
them
or turning the environment on them when
possible Abe can hide in steam vents
lead gun-toting guards into landmines
zap them by activating electric fields
and occasionally he can possess a guard
to temporarily turn his gun on his
comrades Abe's enemies are scary
powerful and they exhibit unique
identities possessing a slick guard lets
you order slugs to kill another guard
para mites won't attack unless you back
them into a corner scrubs will attack on
sight unless they see another scrap in
which case the two will ignore you and
to fight to the death
exploiting these behaviors is the key to
solving most puzzles this mixes well
with the environmental hazards in ways
that never feel repetitive but Abe's
quest isn't solely about
self-preservation along the way he must
free his enslaved human brothers by
issuing them basic commands and leading
them to portals
for all the traumatic ways that Abe can
die in this hostile world there's a
slapstick quality to the dark subject
matter when you have multiple frail Mew
Dawkins in tow the variety of dialogue
in new and tasty has been greatly
increased over the original game so the
Mew Dawkins feel less like carbon copies
of one another and ragdoll physics make
everything funnier trying to survive as
a fragile character like Abe was
something of a novelty when Abe's
Oddysee was first released he died in
one hit but he had unlimited lives the
same is true of new and tasty but this
remake adds three difficulty levels the
easier of which lets you take more than
one hit before dying but even the
classic one hit kill difficulty level is
still forgiving as you can quick save by
simply tapping the touchpad keep this in
mind and you'll rarely lose much
progress from what is sure to be
repeated deaths unfortunately those
deaths sometimes occur because of how
new and tasty uses the analog stick for
movement in the original game you
control Dave's movement speed by holding
down the shoulder buttons this was
important because the game required
precise timing of Sprint's and jumps to
avoid landing on mines or falling down
chasms new and tasty changes this by
putting 2 movement speeds on the left
thumbstick pushing it slightly will make
a walk while pushing it harder will make
him run this led to a number of
situations where I had to adjust my
position by a single step but I ended up
running straight into a landmine
thankfully sneaking is still bound to a
shoulder button so it's rare that you'll
accidentally wake up a Slig and get shot
despite occasional frustrations from
this fiddly analog move
and some fourth wall breaking ingame ads
this is a remake that feels as though it
was crafted with love and respect with
clever puzzles near identical to the
original game and beautiful environments
brought to life with new visuals in a
dynamic camera new and tasty thoroughly
satiated me despite my being an oddball
the veteran and knowing each solution
and secret area like the back of my head
[Music]